fort des pouvoirs que leur attribue
l'état d'urgence les corps policiers
français ont procédé à 128 raids dans
les dernières heures on a appris que les
terroristes avaient loué deux chambres
dans cet hôtel d'alfortville près de
paris dans les jours menant aux
attentats ils ont laissé sur place des
téléphones cellulaires dans un
appartement à bobigny louer ou six par e
on a retrouvé des traces d'explosifs à
alfortville les résidents de l'hôtel
était secoué à paris même ont retrouvé
une autre voiture noire une troisième
immatriculé en belgique qu'à
probablement servait pour les attaques
contre les terrasses de café les
autorités françaises cherchent toujours
celui qui a loué les autos et les
appartements
abdeslam salah après analyse des faits
les policiers croient qu'une personne de
puces a participé aux attentats
l'individu inconnue est toujours en
fuite la police allemande de son côté
procédé à une série de raids près de la
frontière belge et arrêté sept personnes
qu'on croyait liées aux attentats
tous étaient rapidement relâché alors
que l' enquête avance le président
français françois hollande cherche de
plus en plus d'appuis dans la communauté
internationale de secrétaire d'état
américaine john kerry lui rendait visite
pour lui transmettre les condoléances du
président obama et du peuple américain
il soulignait qu' américains et français
collaboraient déjà dans l'est
bombardement des sites du groupe armé
état islamique et que cette coopération
ira en s'accentuant
le président poutine qui vient de
reconnaître que le récent écrasement
d'un avion de passagers russes en egypte
était bel et bien un attentat terroriste
du groupe islamique demande à son armée
de coopérer avec la france qui vient
d'envoyer son porte-avions
charles-de-gaulle près de la syrie que
ce soit en mer ou dans les airs
disait-il il faut aider les forces
françaises de l'exemple de coordination
les aviations russes et françaises
bombarder tout deux le fief du groupe
etat islamique en syrie jaca la nuit
dernière mais le président français
attend bien plus des russes et des
américains il souhaite qu'au lieu de 2
coalition qui bombarde chacune de son
côté assuré qu'il n'y a qu'une seule
science pour combattre le groupe armé
état islamique c'est pour cela qu'il se
rend la semaine prochaine à moscou et à
washington pour tenter de convaincre les
deux grands rivaux de collaborer de
travailler ensemble et c'est raymond
st-pierre radio canada à paris